4 cuando yo bailén llegó a la
presidencia una de las Grandes
esperanzas fue el levantamiento del
título 42 una de sus promesas qué ha
pasado en estos dos años de gobierno
Bueno una de las cosas que intentó el
presidente pero todavía no podía actuar
en ello es quitar el título 42 para que
personas que pueden llegar a la frontera
tengan una oportunidad de pedir asilo en
el país si bien no mencionó como una de
sus campañas al final el día
republicanos y algunos demócratas le
impidieron hacer esto y por eso las
Cortes y tribunales se han se han
documentado en este caso lo que sucedió
ayer Es que la corte dijo que este tipo
de proceso de título 42 no era justo y
tampoco es necesario para las personas y
las personas que llegan a la frontera
pero también para la política del país
lo cual ahora nos regresa a un periodo
en 2019 cuando las personas que llegaron
la frontera podían pedir asilo y muchas
de ellas también cuando entran al país
tendrían que seguir retomando su caso
para hacer para quedarse en el país o
para ser deportados eso va a ser lo que
podemos esperar para los siguientes
meses que llegan y como bien lo
mencionaron empezaría esto empezando a
mediados de diciembre
este bloqueo del título 42 puede atraer
a más migrantes irregulares a la
frontera sur de Estados Unidos esto en
medio de los esfuerzos del gobierno
byden Pues por contener los flujos
migratorios
es un argumento que os hemos escuchado
mucho Y claro que la migración y los
migrantes responden no solamente a
motivaciones económicas o en sus países
de origen pero también a los
motivaciones y cambios en la política de
Estados Unidos en este caso Podemos
esperar que sí en efectivo en los
primeros meses que vemos por ejemplo de
aquí a a marzo veremos a lo mejor algún
aumento en el flujo migratorio en la
frontera ya que más personas buscan
entrar de manera irregular y tan
siquiera pedir de esa manera asilo en el
país pero también tenemos que entender
que este tipo de flujo que estamos
viendo en la frontera tiene que ver más
con falta de acceso a tener aún así uno
en un caso de asilo en el país que
ahorita no existe si tuviésemos mejores
controles para poder procesar Estos
tipos de casos en la frontera es
importante más rápido podríamos ver
quienes de estas personas pueden entrar
al país y cuáles tienen que ser o
podrían ser deportadas a otro país el
título 42 no iba originalmente a
ciudadanos venezolanos pero desde el
acuerdo con México este acuerdo reciente
este grupo de migrantes está en la mira
cómo está su situación en estos momentos
este bloqueo los impacta de alguna
manera
sí efectivamente este acuerdo que se dio
A mediados del mes pasado en octubre se
enfocaba en incluir ahora Venezuela en
este tipo de nacionalidades que pueden
ser repatriadas a México desde Estados
Unidos este esta edición de ya no
continuar con el título 42 impacto
directamente a esa población venezolana
que ahora podrá otra vez llegar la
frontera pedir asilo y algunos de ellos
entran al país vuelvo a recalcar no
solamente porque llegan en la frontera y
sean procesados para ingresar significa
que se van a quedar muchos de ellos
Incluyendo a otras personas por ejemplo
cubanas nicaragüenses tendrán que
terminar su proceso de asilo en
determinación en los tribunales y de ahí
determinar se pueden quedar o no antes
de esto lo que hemos visto desde que
empezó el programa de marzo de 2020
hemos visto que casi 2.4 millones de
personas han sido de vueltas o
expulsadas bajo este proceso de título
42 y cabe mencionar que no solamente son
nacionalidades mexicanas
centroamericanas que también van a ser
afectadas por esto